how many sins have you
committed way too many to count have you
committed a great big pile of sins the
size of a mountain if so has Allah got a
deal for
you most Muslims have absolutely no clue
what their own Prophet said about how
Allah forgives them and rewards them
with Paradise they tend to think that
Allah simply decides to let their sins
slide he sweeps them under the road
pretends they never
happened but that's just not what
Muhammad said most Muslims don't know
what Muhammad said because their leaders
hide it from
them why would shakes and imams hide
what Muhammad said let's find out sahim
Muslim
7011 this is the darus Salam Edition it
uses a different numbering system than
the online edition at sun.com but there
links to the sunnah.com Edition in the
description box in case you want to look
these up it was narrated that Abu Musa
said the messenger of Allah said when
the day of Resurrection comes Allah
glorified and exalted is he will give
every Muslim a Jew or a Christian and he
will say this is your Ransom from the
fire when the day of Resurrection comes
Allah will give give to every Muslim a
Jew or a Christian that Jew or Christian
is the muslim's ransom from
Hell sah Muslim
72 A and S bin ABI BDA narrated that
they witnessed Abu BDA narrating to Umar
bin Abdul aiz from his father that the
prophet said no muslim man dies but
Allah causes a Jew or a Christian to
enter the fire in his
stead if you're a Muslim and you die
Allah will send a Jew or a Christian to
hell in your
place sah Muslim 73 is a similar Hadith
but it's narrated by katar sah Muslim
714 it was narrated from Abu BDA from
his father that the prophet said on the
day of Resurrection some Muslim people
will come with sins like mountains but
Allah will forgive them and will place
them the sins on the Jews and the
Christians you can have mountains of
sins not to worry Allah will take those
sins and put them on the Jews and
Christians and the Jews and Christians
will pay for your mountain of sins in
Hell 110 a Hadith KY number 8 narrated
Abu Musa Allah's messenger said on the
day of Resurrection ction my umah nation
will be gathered into three groups one
sort will enter Paradise without
rendering an account of their deeds
another sort will be reckoned an easy
account and admitted into Paradise yet
another sort will come bearing on their
backs heaps of sins like great mountains
Allah will ask the Angels though he
knows best about them who are these
people they will reply they're humble
slaves of yours he will say unload the
sins from them and put the same over the
Jews and Christians then let the humble
slaves get into Paradise by virtue of my
mercy here Allah orders the angels to
unload the great mountains of sins from
Muslims and to put those mountains of
sins on the Jews and the
Christians so if you're a muslim with a
mountain of sins does Allah simply
forgive you
no someone has to pay for what you've
done who pays for your sins according to
Muhammad I
do or some other Christian does or some
Jew
does historically there are way more
Christians than Jews so it's much more
likely that a Christian will be paying
for your mountain of sins this means of
course that in an interesting way I'm
your
savior your Prophet says that your
salvation comes from
me I'm your Ransom from hell I pay for
your ticket to
Paradise do you want me to be your
savior do you want some other Christian
or a Jew to be your savior I'll go ahead
and say it a little thank you David
thank you Christians and Jews for
rescuing Us From Hell would be nice
according to your Prophet Christians and
Jews are literally paying for the most
expensive gift you've ever been given
show some
gratitude and you're
welcome now I ask you Muslims who are
watching why is this the first time
you're hearing about any of
this why don't your leaders ever tell
you what your Prophet said about Jews
and Christians paying for your sins
well because their goal isn't for you to
understand Islamic theology their goal
is to keep you confident so you don't
leave Islam and they do this by lying to
you in order to give you a false
confidence for instance since the Bible
was copied by hand for centuries there
are textual variant in the manuscripts
spelling differences copious mistakes
and so on the same is true of the Quran
the same is true of any book that human
beings copied by
hand but for decades your leaders lied
to you and said that the Quran is
different from every other book every
copy of the Quran in the entire world is
exactly the same right down to the
letter zero textual variance it was a
total lie but they wanted you to feel
like there's something special about
your book to give you a false
confidence when it comes to Salvation
they do the same thing they say look
Christians claim that Jesus willingly
died on the cross for your sins but how
can one person pay for the sins of
another person isn't that completely
unjust that's why Islam is better in
Islam people pay for their own sins
that's
just they obviously can't give you this
false confidence this false sense that
Islam is somehow more just than
Christianity if you know what Muhammad
said about Allah punishing Jews and
Christians in heav for your sins so they
hide it from you and they lie to
you this raises an important
question if your Scholars are lying to
you about matters as important as
salvation and the history of your
book what else are they lying about
[Music]